that this crisis was an opportunity for Greece, for Europe,
for the world, to make radical democratic transformations
in our institutions.
Instead, I had a very humbling experience.
In Brussels, when we tried desperately again and again
to find common solutions,
I realized that not one, not one of us,
had ever dealt with a similar crisis.
But worse, we were trapped by our collective ignorance.
We were led by our fears.
And our fears led to a blind faith
in the orthodoxy of austerity.
Instead of reaching out to the common
or the collective wisdom in our societies,
investing in it to find more creative solutions,
we reverted to political posturing.
And then we were surprised when every
ad hoc new measure didn't bring an end to the crisis,
and of course that made it very easy
to look for a whipping boy
for our collective European failure,
and of course that was Greece.
Those profligate, idle, ouzo-swilling, Zorba-dancing Greeks,
they are the problem. Punish them!
Well, a convenient but unfounded stereotype
that sometimes hurt even more than austerity itself.
But let me warn you, this is not just about Greece.
This could be the pattern
that leaders follow again and again
when we deal with these complex, cross-border problems,
whether it's climate change, whether it's migration,
whether it's the financial system.
That is, abandoning our collective power
to imagine our potential,
falling victims to our fears, our stereotypes, our dogmas,
taking our citizens out of the process
rather than building the process around our citizens.
And doing so will only test the faith
of our citizens, of our peoples, even more
in the democratic process.
It's no wonder that many political leaders,
and I don't exclude myself,
have lost the trust of our people.
When riot police have to protect parliaments,
a scene which is increasingly common around the world,
then there's something deeply wrong with our democracies.
That's why I called for a referendum to have the Greek people
own and decide on the terms of the rescue package.
My European counterparts, some of them, at least,
said, "You can't do this.
There will be havoc in the markets again."
I said, "We need to, before we restore confidence in the markets,
we need to restore confidence and trust amongst our people."
Since leaving office, I have had time to reflect.
We have weathered the storm, in Greece and in Europe,
but we remain challenged.
If politics is the power to imagine and use our potential,
well then 60-percent youth unemployment in Greece,
and in other countries, certainly is a lack of imagination
if not a lack of compassion.
So far, we've thrown economics at the problem,
actually mostly austerity,
and certainly we could have designed alternatives,
a different strategy, a green stimulus for green jobs,
or mutualized debt, Eurobonds which would
support countries in need from market pressures,
these would have been much more viable alternatives.
Yet I have come to believe that the problem is not so much
one of economics as it is one of democracy.
So let's try something else.
Let's see how we can bring people back to the process.
Let's throw democracy at the problem.
Again, the Ancient Greeks, with all their shortcomings,
believed in the wisdom of the crowd
at their best moments. In people we trust.
Democracy could not work without the citizens
deliberating, debating, taking on public responsibilities
for public affairs.
Average citizens often were chosen for citizen juries
to decide on critical matters of the day.
Science, theater, research, philosophy,
games of the mind and the body,
they were daily exercises.
Actually they were an education for participation,
for the potential, for growing the potential of our citizens.
And those who shunned politics, well, they were idiots.
You see, in Ancient Greece, in ancient Athens,
that term originated there.
"Idiot" comes from the root "idio," oneself.
A person who is self-centered, secluded, excluded,
someone who doesn't participate or even examine public affairs.
And participation took place in the agora, the agora having two meanings,
both a marketplace and a place where there was political deliberation.
You see, markets and politics then were one, unified,
accessible, transparent, because they gave power to the people.
They serve the demos, democracy.
Above government, above markets
was the direct rule of the people.
Today we have globalized the markets
but we have not globalized our democratic institutions.
So our politicians are limited to local politics,
while our citizens, even though they see a great potential,
are prey to forces beyond their control.
So how then do we reunite the two halves of the agora?
How do we democratize globalization?
And I'm not talking about the necessary reforms
of the United Nations or the G20.
I'm talking about, how do we secure the space,
the demos, the platform of values,
so that we can tap into all of your potential?
Well, this is exactly where I think Europe fits in.
Europe, despite its recent failures,
is the world's most successful cross-border peace experiment.
So let's see if it can't be an experiment
in global democracy, a new kind of democracy.
Let's see if we can't design a European agora,
not simply for products and services,
but for our citizens, where they can work together,
deliberate, learn from each other,
exchange between art and cultures,
where they can come up with creative solutions.
Let's imagine that European citizens
actually have the power to vote directly
for a European president,
or citizen juries chosen by lottery
which can deliberate on critical and controversial issues,
a European-wide referendum where our citizens,
as the lawmakers, vote on future treaties.
And here's an idea:
Why not have the first truly European citizens
by giving our immigrants,
not Greek or German or Swedish citizenship,
but a European citizenship?
And make sure we actually empower
the unemployed by giving them a voucher scholarship
where they can choose to study anywhere in Europe.
Where our common identity is democracy,
where our education is through participation,
and where participation builds trust
and solidarity rather than exclusion and xenophobia.
Europe of and by the people,
a Europe, an experiment in deepening and widening
democracy beyond borders.
Now, some might accuse me of being naive,
putting my faith in the power and the wisdom of the people.
Well, after decades in politics, I am also a pragmatist.
Believe me, I have been,
I am, part of today's political system,
and I know things must change.
We must revive politics as the power to imagine,
reimagine, and redesign for a better world.
But I also know that this disruptive force of change
won't be driven by the politics of today.
The revival of democratic politics
will come from you, and I mean all of you.
Everyone who participates in this global exchange of ideas,
whether it's here in this room
or just outside this room
or online or locally, where everybody lives,
everyone who stands up to injustice and inequality,
everybody who stands up to those who preach
racism rather than empathy,
dogma rather than critical thinking,
technocracy rather than democracy,
everyone who stands up to the unchecked power,
whether it's authoritarian leaders,
plutocrats hiding their assets in tax havens,
or powerful lobbies protecting the powerful few.
It is in their interest that all of us are idiots.
Let's not be.
Thank you.
(Applause)
Bruno Giussani: You seem to describe a political leadership
that is kind of unprepared
and a prisoner of the whims of the financial markets,
and that scene in Brussels that you describe, to me,
as a citizen, is terrifying.
Help us understand how you felt after the decision.
It was not a good decision, clearly,
but how do you feel after that, not as the prime minister,
but as George?
George Papandreou: Well, obviously there were constraints
which didn't allow me or others to make
the types of decisions we would have wanted,
and obviously I had hoped that we would have the time
to make the reforms which would have dealt
with the deficit rather than trying to cut the deficit
which was the symptom of the problem.
And that hurt. That hurt because that, first of all,
hurt the younger generation, and not only,
many of them are demonstrating outside,
but I think this is one of our problems.
When we face these crises, we have kept the potential,
the huge potential of our society out of this process,
and we are closing in on ourselves in politics,
and I think we need to change that, to really find
new participatory ways using the great capabilities
that now exist even in technology but not only in technology,
the minds that we have, and I think we can find solutions
which are much better, but we have to be open.
BG: You seem to suggest that the way forward
is more Europe, and that is not to be an easy discourse
right now in most European countries.
It's rather the other way -- more closed borders
and less cooperation and maybe even stepping out
of some of the different parts of the European construction.
How do you reconcile that?
GP: Well, I think one of the worst things that happened
during this crisis is that we started a blame game.
And the fundamental idea of Europe is that
we can cooperate beyond borders,
go beyond our conflicts and work together.
And the paradox is that, because we have this blame game,
we have less the potential to convince our citizens
that we should work together,
while now is the time when we really need
to bring our powers together.
Now, more Europe for me is not simply
giving more power to Brussels.
It is actually giving more power to the citizens of Europe,
that is, really making Europe a project of the people.
So that, I think, would be a way to answer
some of the fears that we have in our society.
BG: George, thank you for coming to TED.
GP: Thank you very much.BG: Thank you.(Applause)